all right i'm gonna go see about a
campaign is there anything i should
specifically do uh what do you mean
specifically is there any campaign that
you guys like
that works better you're battle hardened
why are you battle-hardened
i think special version of the game of
prayer like the ultimate edition or
something probably oh all right so i'm
gonna put it on veteran because we're
good at this game right
yeah veterans should be good yeah yeah
or nightmare yeah yeah definitely that
if you want a really short sweet video
nightmare is the way to go i mean do you
want my nightmare yeah yeah all right
okay you know i think it could be it
could be fun i uh haven't played much
but i like it so far it gets uh it gets
really tough on veteran difficulty i
will tell you that funny it's on holly i
can't imagine what nightmare's gonna
look like i'm sure it's fine i mean
i'm a pretty good fps man what are
corruption cards those are the bad
things mark yeah so you get to choose
your deck and there's also some random
corruption event cards that pop up every
time you do a level two we're going with
slumber party
oh all of these are active oh never mind
they're all there oh what the bonus
stuff you have to do the copper one so
it's uh
not go down any more than two times with
the bonus copper
all right easy yeah easy
easy
supply points are how you unlock more
cards your coppers like just get this
run
until we die
they leave behind pools of acid cool
cool
you all right there turn your bash into
a knife dude combat knife nice nice nice
knife
knife nice nice knife nice knife nice
knife nice hmm nice you have to do an
intro and all those fancy bits no
i already did it if they want to play
this game they can use the link in the
description to use my creator code
markiplier on the epic game store oh
cool
yeah it is pretty cool creator code
creator code all right well i'm swinging
swinging machete we could have pulled
together got the support item upgrade
but that's okay what does it even mean
okay so do you see the far right your
gun
has a gray bar and whatever your
starting item was has a gray bar you
actually upgrade the quality of it
through the box so if you upgrade
support item upgrade means that your
healing items would do more they'd be
upgraded so you can go from gray to
green to blue to purple i don't know if
you go to gold or not but it goes up the
gold at least for attachments for guns
now i spend it on another gun
[Music]
i feel very good about my purchase
it's a shotgun with a scope dude sick
that's good you're not worth it
i'm not talking about you i was shopping
for my own thing
i guess it did kind of sound a little
bit like
that's not worth it you know yeah
your purchases are awful and you should
feel bad i do not all right i'm gonna
open that lower yeah i'm gonna open the
door
door's open all right don't kill me i'm
gonna be in in front with a sword all
right
oh that looks special
oh a tall man
oh no i shot walker in the face i shot
walker oh there he's gone oh he's fine
stop stop stop it usually a melee does
this and left for nothing apparently
oh my god how am i this low on health
already well there's a tall boy beating
the crap out of you no no no i'm in this
room off to the side by myself oh that's
me with you then okay cool where there's
another one there's a big thing tank
thing oh i'm dead boy why am i
dead kill them
no they're all acid
like all of them
and i'll get you buddy don't worry buddy
i got your pal i'm getting you walking
walker
okay
well here's an mp5 with some attachments
and a pistol with some attachments
hey i got a glock ooh
green mag
bob where are you i'm gonna heal you up
hey i'm right here copper
some
i opened the door oh i know if it was a
breakdown or not there you go have a
stop oh did i go too far forward
i got intel i don't know what india
means
oh so that's a free car that's a free
perk where'd you grab that it was up
here uh off to the left in the now cove
see anyone's name right here oh right
here
watch out walkers is standing in the
group
i knew this scope would come in handy
okay
uh we've got some stuff over here stun
guns and so on
um
the stun will automatically get you uh
released
oh
i have a stun and there's also a uh uh
uh
ammo thing in the ammo pouch
we can also drop ammo for each other if
we're using different kinds of guns
right
oh
there's meds up here
oh god we need that oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] there's a big there's a big he's at
the door he's big
oh he's big
he explodes
i forgot how that works
it's fascinating because he doesn't look
like a typical exploder you know fat and
bloated he just looks like very stocky
but uh
yeah he blows
oh bad thing down here whoa
hey ow how'd you hit me
oh
ridiculous range
ridiculous
swinging arm bob i can save you i've got
the defibrillator
oh yeah he's dead can i count on you
thanks
why am i taking damage ah
it might be an acid that i can't see
here oh no i just only have 16 health
thanks dude you're welcome
that'll fix it are you guys ready to
trigger a [ __ ] of course yeah so what
was that the intro stuff that was the
opportunity for the first level now
nightmare mode really begins oh behind
us big exploder in the doorway
great you got this right wade you got
this blade uh-oh your battle is not good
you're battle hardened you're hard from
battle harder how hard you are when you
get and you get uh
pumped hey at least maybe the problem
was that mark's shotgun didn't have a
powerful enough scope you're right i
only had two times not five times maybe
we're gonna be doing this on a nightmare
we've got a band together
can we
maybe not do that maybe go veteran i get
plus 10 team health oh
yeah walker's pretty good
yeah mom gives the whole team an extra
life i think so if like we all go down
we get to continue i think which is nice
oh mom
mom
is this veteran
this is veteran oh excellent look at
there's only two corruption cards
headshots and don't go down
and that's well
we were really not good at that earlier
so yeah we'll see about that all right
you guys ready uh should i spend my cash
on anything i'm sure i have a lot of
cash um it's good to save up sometimes
you can get like the 1500 points
that's what i was doing yeah that sounds
good yeah that sounds good
i mean if you need to buy stuff you buy
stuff lead also
uh
damn it
i should check the room for zombies
first
yeah that's a good start
there's a a nod a nade and a sneaker
over here a naughty oh a 1911 yeah dude
oh um pills
hills here drugs you got drugs
hello you scared me i forgot you existed
i just dropped some wire which is
definitely useful for upstairs if anyone
wants to grab it evangelo was stuck in
the okay
there's an acog here
taking that hey
wait i think i saw a big guy
wait yeah there's a big guy there
i did see a big guy
i knew i did
i don't think he should be able to hit
through a door oh frame
seems like he shouldn't be able to
power of the tall tall boys is very i
don't know what they're actually called
i don't actually call it all boys
molly
over here bandage too ah
thank you got him
you guys all have a healing item there's
abandoned no i will take the bandages
i got the card that spawns more money
around and i can see it through walls so
i love money
that sounds big something sounds big
that's big uh outside uh mark
mark it's right there
[Music]
oh my god
is it better
thank you okay thank you everyone
all over again pipe bomb
pipe bombs are very good oh those are
cool
oh
hey hi how you doing
take that if you see a red attachment on
a gun by the way red means it's broken
oh oh why is it even there uh somebody
maybe wants to heal up with the thingies
all right i'll get you wade
are you sure all right thank you thanks
sally no i'm good see i'm a pro at this
game i don't take that you are all right
then i'm just going to start this up you
guys ready to lower the words
yeah man yeah dude yeah dude
look i'll put fire on this bridge
nothing going to get through watch this
watch this
oh they come out of the windows
hello
well this seems much more manageable
than the last yeah
something's different you know something
feels different
yeah i gotta be honest from nightmare to
this is kind of nuts
no don't do it
evangelo move or something dude
god dang
there we go it's just standing there
this is much more manageable
like much
i sort of thought i could continue to
get ammo so i really used a lot there
but the ammo pile is apparently empty
even though it's also still there
no no no it's gone
uh axe
i got an explosive in my hand so we have
a big dude we can throw this and blow
him up
can you blow open that door that needs a
tool
giggle guys i gotta do a deer girl oh
a good a dick eagle
nice
can you strip the parts off of a gun
that you have
where's that ammo at ammo
oh [ __ ] dude
i'm going down
nice ow
did you hit me
no there's fall oh i thought of angela
okay big
there's a big if you guys look up in
here there's a big warning about
watching your step on the ladder big
dude
dude coming in there he is
dead
how do you watch your step on the ladder
though that's my question oh you just
walk off rather than jump off
i didn't jump off i walked off and i it
still sucked i jumped off
yeah well i'm not an idiot so i'm not an
idiot either
[Music]
over here with the arm he's about to oh
ow
and you get chucked
there's a lot of birds frangelo please
check out this garage here probably oh
fine
there's fire
pickles it's on fire
no whoa hey the fire is pretty real one
of us gets a free heal on this and the
the trauma that we have the red and
black on our health bar will be healed
up by that too
i guess it should be you wade that's
like unhealable right you need you need
something
other upgrades with cards or yeah the
those specific big dude you still get
heals on it but it costs 400 copper big
dude has no idea
are we
we letting him go
why not did you get the heel yeah you
got the heel okay bygone bygone
hello
who's shooting is that of angela
evangelo no the big dude sees us now
i don't think
how could he
man an evangel was kind of good
oh bob bob we moved ahead
i'm surprised that didn't alert the
birds
every every zombie screech just makes me
think of new metal oh
so
don't shoot the birds is that what we've
decided the plan is yeah
okay
okay i can do that i can do that lmg
here
god he's a badass
[Music]
man evangelo really took a lot of damage
there so what do we go in the safe room
now or just hang out here yes so what do
we go in the safe room
i'm just looking there's an ammo box
[Music]
hi friend
hello do you get like topped up on ammo
if you in the safe room sort of feel or
not really i mean he's a shop so once we
close the store i think it's a store
that accesses
like that
yeah
nice oh we did it guys we're veterans we
did it we're so good i feel battle
hardened as much as waden exactly maybe
even more
[Laughter]
so high the computer can't process it
it's wrapped all the way around that's
actually over nine hundred ninety nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine yeah i
kicked back around to zero absolutely
i'm ready for nightmare difficulty
honestly i can't imagine i turn it back
up i can't believe how big of a jump it
is from this difficulty to that
difficulty usually there's like at least
four increments some of it's also the
luck of the draw with the cards you pull
too oh more bird
two extra birds angelo loves birds he
loves birds oh evangelo he loves guys go
ahead and ammo pouch myself
i got his extra copper piles
i got also extra copper piles oh there's
guys so many copper also don't forget to
reload your secondary because for some
reason every time you start a level your
secondary is empty you want me to reload
my bat
is that what you want me to do yeah let
me load your back reload
get it out mark and just oh gosh
i'm trying to get loaded oh sorry oh my
god i'm so sorry
what are you doing nothing
nothing happened
you seemed to be aiming at me no no just
inspecting reloading my okay well i
bought a defibrillator okay i bought so
i can save one of us i've got a tool kit
so i can open one of those uh special
doors every place cool i'm opening this
special door they're they're birds all
right i could hear them so be careful
with all the zombies
uh smg over there
according to evangelo
is there anything explosive or anything
around here
that one
exploded
we're gonna we're gonna miss that's cool
man so hot fire well if angela we're
really stuck over here now molotov on me
hey um guys
oh
is that good oh okay
well
look out behind
i'm trying
oh what's the most effective way to help
you
it's big
hey guys i need some birds
oh i got razor wire hang on did it
where'd it go i didn't put it down the
big thing it's on me
this thing's big
what do we do what do we do what do we
do what do we do
uh i've got a horde of little dudes i
gotta get rid of come on
stop being alive
whoa
oh jesus there's a lot of bad things
going on over here there sure are i am
reloading i have 10 health left
he takes up the entire area where do i
kite him
uh uh good question all right don't
worry bob i'll get you well he really
guys i have aggro somehow
don't worry i'm keeping aggro oh no he's
throwing him don't don't you're throwing
his areas quantum
i'm taunting call them mean names
ow
hey you big gross
piece of garbage
how you doing you you like that you suck
what happened to the birds
maybe we can uh they were disturbed
oh ow
don't worry guys i'll fish him off
oh
no
oh mark seems to have died
what happened to me
i don't know you just webbed
for a minute there a stinger somewhere
oh
okay
well that's unfair makes you feel any
better i shot you after you got webbed
hoping it would free you thank you
[Laughter]
this is the convergence of those well no
one could break you free i was like well
maybe shooting it would help yeah um did
it
alright
well hey now you guys know there's a big
dude that there's a big dude yeah i
should have set up my barbed wire sooner
i would have stopped him
don't worry guys watch this drink a
barber
that does nothing it stopped them oh it
did okay
that does nothing
they were running at you and then they
were all
and then they weren't running at you all
right you know what i was a little bit
scared and i closed my eyes and i
covered my face
there's like a big guy down there
evangel you might want to give the big
guy
oh you guys got it save that hey i was i
carried that
oh do you want it back no it's okay you
can do whatever you're doing
whatever that is
there's a so how close do we have to get
oh okay
oh
shoot me wait shoot me i'm webbed
you're in the shed i'm coming
i got hit into the shed i got
don't worry my barbed wire
long enough for me to revive you it's
not stopping it's not stopping them it's
not
oh no i don't want to be alive i'm so
slow
wait you seem to be taking quite a lot
of damage
i scared the birds
hey guys
all right hang on watch this
dodge right tweet
bricks the legs
quick legs twix twix twix the legs ah no
i got him i'm going to bat this ogre's
ankles to death he's never going to see
what's coming are you laying on the
ground with your back i'm twixt his legs
get him and get him in the groondle i'm
getting him in the grindle i'm dead i'm
dead in the grindel oh i'm
okay okay it seemed a little unfair
effort they they really
like suddenly a lot came at once it's
deceptive because the first thing we did
previously to this level that wasn't
like that well both times we upset the
birds which just spawns another horde
when the boss spawns he brings a bunch
of dudes with them but upsetting the
birds
uh doubled that well
that one started off really
unfortunately because i literally
the big arm guy hit me into the shed
and then i was just yeah and then i was
just like oh okay
yeah i was trying to catch you dead now
and then one of the exploding guys
blasted me as far away from the shed as
possible
do we have to start at the beginning
again or do we get to move to where we
just died i think i can start us on the
second level but we'll get to select an
extra card but we have less chance of
finding like some of the upgrades it
won't be a big deal i'll go ahead and
start on the second one so we can just
pick up there awesome
all right ready when you guys you may
start it yeah i'm ready
veteran difficulty
level two of act one
did you shoot me
no i did you must have got blowback
oh i can't shoot in here no
i'll get you i'll get you from the
doorway
[Music]
i go to select starting point and the
second level says pain train but that
was the third level maybe you can't
start at that checkpoint maybe that
checkpoint is in the middle of it maybe
i'll just start at the beginning again
okay mastodon milk there's a protein
powder here called mastodon milk i like
that i think mastodons are extinct i'm
pretty sure well their milk still
persists it's like oil you dig it up
exactly do you harvest mass you have to
dig deep and find their memories
you go down i zoned out for like two
seconds
gotta dig deep and find those mastodon
memories oh
it's beautiful beautiful thing
i'm not gonna start with my copper
finder i did you know what specimen
sampling bird call
good here mark extra copper i'll do
copper too oh thanks man you got the
right oh are we doing copper we're doing
a copper rod and copper all right i'll
do some copper copper as copper heavy as
we can let's all ass i got a tool kit so
we find a secret door i got a tool kit
secret tunnel
cigarettes
i'm playing the belgian
i am also playing the belgian i'm double
shotgun and this is probably a great
strategy
a bob did you want one of these
attachments
um
no i already have a mag i like well i'll
take it on my other one i guess
i hear the gurgles why
ah
man the
it's not very good when i run out of
ammo
what do you do ammo for no i mean my my
gun my gun was out of ammo i don't know
i don't have a bat anymore big big boomy
wait what boom big boom big boomy big
booty i can't run
so much money wow
over here you gotta chill out and you
need to stop shooting so close to me my
dude dude angelo is a loose cannon can i
take the attachment off of something and
then
unfortunately unless you find another
attachment of the same type you can swap
it and then get it back out that way
specimen container
oh but my tool hang on
someone else grab it bob bob grab it
what you'll love it if you don't have a
we don't want to drop our toolkit you'll
love it well i have a stun gun
the tool kit's more valuable but the
stun gun also sucks well we're going to
use a toolkit on the next here because
that's where the door was that's true
next we run back yeah we'll run back
we'll run back we'll run back i will run
back baby
i'm calling them guys i have a sniper
rifle that's awesome
whoa tall boy
nice wow it does a lot of damage
why isn't my
barbed wire float with them even a
little bit that's what i was saying
and bob called me crazy for not thinking
that it uh sorry mom you are crazy bob i
just stabbed you in the neck i apologize
that didn't feel great
if i'm honest there's an exploding uh we
have two specials up here
oh
oh oh oh
oh something big behind me just exploded
explode your spot eventually you want to
blow it up
on evangel there he goes watch out for
the cowboy oh no he grabbed me
i didn't realize that was an option
oh
yeah i thought that big arm was only for
some i didn't even yeah i thought he was
a more smasher not a grabber yeah that's
not cool
bro that's not cool bro
hey a tool
boy it's a toolkit guys fall back
nah fall forward
oh maybe back i'll get him i'll get him
i'm i'm spinning her he doesn't know
what's happening
got him
all forward
this looks fun
pretty decent vector there a sniper
rifle oh that's a better sniper rifle
than i have there's an even better
sniper rifle right here the the m95
lots of snipers i have a better one did
you want to go grab the thing that bob
dropped or the other toolkit mark
uh
there was actually a toolkit that
spawned right here
so we have extras
don't worry i got a silencer okay
i think you mean
it's like it's just like the sound of
someone's last breath
up to the ladder you climb down it
no you don't i did it
i literally slowly walked up to it
you don't take damage if you land over
here idiots birds on the left birds on
the left uh are killing the birds
killing birds
oh oh there's one by the birds i don't
like that guys my shotgun's quiet i can
shoot the birds
boost away
they're coming from the insides as well
oh he's coming whoa he's big oh he's got
me
god damn there's a lot of them
way to go wade this is not entirely my
fault
uh-huh
so at some point we got to blame the
birds yeah the damn birds yeah it seems
like suddenly this is much harder than
it was previously
that fire's real close to those birds
it's fine
i think we got to go on the ground it
seems fine i don't i don't know how
we're going to get around those guys i
mean you can go down on the ground right
yeah i'm going to go down yes thank you
whoever just hang the smg again lmg
there's birds on the left oh i see them
it's okay marcus is the silent killer
he's like heart disease you'll never see
him coming
you're like at hq like uh breaker burger
has his heart disease coming in hot you
guys got the gates open ready for me
disease coming in
breaker breaker this is a fib uh
stalking from the shadows
oh there's a lot of explosives in here
maybe don't shoot those while i'm near
them
oh we got another tall boy coming
yeah we do
nice oh it's a good thing there's not
too many birds around here
jeez
all right time to move out
ah he's out of here goodbye i guess it's
you wade all right oh [ __ ] birds on the
left
on the right
ah so much gold copper white copper why
is it copper uh penny for their thoughts
it's funny
because they said it was funny do you
get it
i'm i'm laughing i don't like the way
evangelo is pointing his gun directly at
my face
all right we're safe finally
i feel so safe thank god we're safe i
feel safe i feel so safe don't worry
i'll protect you
just don't
move
don't move a muscle you got an infected
on your face
[Music]
if anything comes up behind you i'll
just shoot right around let me tell you
what oh
does that mean that they won't see us
too i'm sure though
no they can't see through
either sure
come on man oh it's foggy in here too
oh god it's literally everywhere you got
phil he really oh wow there's a really
cool fog yeah do you guys want these
attachments
what's happening i'm like i'm looking at
attachment
oh just attachments all over the ground
a barrel attack no i have an epic
silencer wait hang on there's a bandage
no hang on i need to make a switch leave
that there
watch this switch that out
switch this wham yes
my shotgun's great oh it's foggy
i'm for the whispers nothing some
spitting tape won't fix
watch out for the birds
that is quiet that's very quiet mark
thank you no one knew a thing
[Music]
hey there's birds to the right i don't
know if anyone's talking to the birds
behind us and get this copper
pile rifle here oh that seems worth it
god evangelo's so helpful evangelist
really concerned about the birds wade
yeah i imagine he is
this will be used i know
of angela evangel can you
can you turn around and look at all the
he's shooting at the birds he's
literally shooting at the bird
he's just eyeballing that's crazy
i think guys can i try and stay up here
for the boss fight oh yeah yeah we can
just try to pull them back okay there's
gas and uh because i can snipe at them
from here and so i can i can i can help
okay cool yeah we'll just i'll run out
and grab them
just be careful like special ads that
spawn too oh no nothing's gonna spawn
and uh the birds don't forget that the
birds exist there's no birds here
they're no but they're still back here
oh i hear that
here he comes hair geared here bad
feeling but you know i forgot about the
fog running away i'm running away
evangelo we're coming back here buddy
angelo pal friend
what's the app help me please hit me
help me
oh oh oh oh oh oh god
well
evangelo's down
all right good he gave it his best
effort just watch the birds
watching those birds
trying to keep ads off your back mark
there's a lot of ads on your back yeah
there are a lot of ads on my back i'm
gonna get up here why am i on the ground
oh my god yeah you staggered him
what's he doing oh god he grabbed me
that's what he was doing oh
um i'm trying to out can you get mark
wait yeah
i'll cover you
leaving already here he's going away
yeah he grabbed me and he was doing a
strange thing like a reach around type
maneuver and i didn't like it you get an
evangelo i can't really cover you that
much question jumping
special
that's terrifying i'm very dead i don't
have a i don't have a difference i have
a fur fibulator hang on i gotta
okay cool good good good good good cool
cool cool cool
i can't be in my special upstairs spot
anymore i don't like that okay don't
worry about it
pooch's evangelo came rocketing past me
oh watch out something
that's why i evangelist behind us
oh what happened watch out for the birds
oh he's hurting oh he's squirting he's
hurt squirting
oh i think he's the you think he's
getting the birds running away okay
i think it's going for the birds dude i
did so much damage with the sniper rifle
i bet you did
that was a really good head shot right
onto your head
my bad it's all good i'm just glad you
had a good shot it was also really quiet
you know
oh
evangelo's tanking them there's two
there's two
that's not good
that's too many that's one too many than
we wanted
he's dead got him oh i made his arm go
playing
oh there's other ones though watch out
boys oh wait
hey
wade oh shotguns are too dangerous the
spread you gotta get silencer
would never no he'd never wake up the
car
oh i guess you're right
yeah cars cars are mainly spooked by
loud noises i know this we know this oh
something's big in the tunnel
it's in the it's right there yeah there
it is
that's a lot of zombos
the vegas just sort of chilling yeah
he's chilling there's two bigs actually
what the [ __ ]
he successfully puked on me i killed him
i killed him there was a police car
right there guys yeah uh so what shoot
it don't shoot it what's the deal
i don't know give me that
it's fine
i think if it was already not alarmed
that would've been bad how could it go
off twice if you guys see any sniper
ammo
i really burned through quite a bit how
do i drop ammo yeah find us find us
nevermind he's dead how do you do this i
hit tab and on the bottom you can drag
and drop that i don't know i am now full
you can have that back all right if
anyone got shotgun
i need shotguns so i can't give you that
oh i need trout well i don't need all my
shotguns
right here
where oh the shock i did ping that oh
isn't there isn't no that's rifle hell
yeah
thank you locked doors have alarms that
can alert the herd
this door is alarmed but i'll use my
tool kit to open it
up
it worked
like magic honker what's a honker it's
fine it's dead
i really caught that in the face yeah
you guys said look out and i turned
around and ran right into him
it's right
there look out for sniper there bob
i'm actually
over here
oh i sense meds in here there's no meds
in here
zero uh where are you at mark oh you
have a lot of trauma
dude evangelo has no trauma what what
heck
mark do you still need shotgun ammo
always
there's some behind you
behind you i mean behind you i'm dealing
with zombies my dude it's not like i
didn't know where it was i was just
dealing with stuff all quiet like that's
fair it's behind you mark
you got it
i found a first aid cabinet that i'm
using greedily that's a good angelo is
staring at the never mind he woke up hey
mark look he found a big guy
hit him hit him boom
oh my man could i just use oh god
hey buddy
there's another one
ow
you know what evangelo we all kind of
need some help it's a zombie apocalypse
well done uh either mark or me should
use this thing to
on trauma uh it's already mark already
used it so now it costs 400 copper oh
bad oh well that's not a bad deal can i
use it again
yeah uh yeah actually can i use it for
the 400. i'll use it
the cost does not go up it stays at 400.
oh good
oh big i'll make it bigger
always when i heal
always right when i what's this what's
going on here oh the needs of many 50s
sure to be able to use it that's okay
i'm not here here i got i dude i'm rich
dude i'm [ __ ] loaded boom bro
thank you i'm not gonna give you any it
sounds like you have enough
something's really working up loogie
over here
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait help ow
okay
that seems crazy
yeah the red pog is like extra fog
and the melee is actually pretty good i
don't use it enough big big big arm arm
arms
uh
where are you guys what are you guys
over here uh here my ass handed to me by
arms mcgee
evangelo's down evangelo's down
oh this is a lot oh my god you guys i am
dying no you're not no you're not not
today the angelo is just coated in blood
that went well
how many copper is it to heal i might
need two oh exploding no no no no no no
okay
maybe we need to go forward
yeah
all right
oh tool kit door yes
perfect oh looks like some good stuffs
in here
see that this rifle here i guess i could
put in a cog
there's an egg
wait wait but i wait i have a sniper can
i have that oh free healing
well wait it looks like and never mind
evangelo just
took it
oh but he didn't take the free charge
oh he didn't no go use that weight
that's good the best bloater
uh
[Music]
dude all my stuff is so crusty with
blood and whatnots it's kind of awesome
but those are kind of gross
is that affected in the long run like
you said things could get damaged is
that how it gets
don't just damaged at me
he he really was just watching huh you
really ran over and just looked at me
so stupid i walked right through you got
you guys you got yours
oh guys we really need to kill the big
thing before okay we're ready to kill
the other big thing before oh okay
no you're not
i'm not in the room with your help
oh good luck guys
okay
i have a defrost later don't worry about
it
there's a wall a bad okay
coming to get you
don't worry guys i'm meleeing him this
will work
oh okay
hey can someone get me up i got you
i'm good thanks for asking always here
for you mom
thanks babe
i think we failed our bonus objective
mission failed successfully there's
another tall guy
oh there's another one he's dead there's
another tall
guy oh my god oh my god i'm dead behind
you
i don't know where they're coming from
bob
i'm down oh my god i'm down in a pretty
decent spot for fixing me
there's oh
there's a grabby hand in here wade i
don't know if you want to come in here
okay guys uh guys uh guys all right mark
oh no
you got it mark fight him off
uh-huh
things done spawning behind us for a
minute
i don't know
i think i'm drawing his ire
he's ironing me good excellent oh i'm
out of ammo
oh god
well thank god i just landed in some
fire and pain
are you trying to
save evangelo the [ __ ]
he's almost dead
get him get him i'll cut his ankles i'm
reloading smack him flick him there's so
much fire
he's dead oh
my god
there's so much fire here i think i'm
getting you
why is there fire right here
why are you guys inside the uh the
unending fire
yeah why is there just constant fire
okay
okay i don't know
angela if you run into the fire and die
evangelist finished it you did it we did
it
no we did it
yeah
who just shot right into my ass jeez
that would be evangelo martin mark mark
mark
that's uh
oh where where's the end where's the end
can we get to the end someone want to
give me uh ammo and
what kind of ammo shotgun ammo
would be great i'm right there
i'm meleeing the hell out of everything
mark swap me out shotgun yourself
shotgunning up
here they come behind us that up front
bad on me
i'm getting so
no you aren't hey thanks
oh that's not good
no that's bad
i have nine health yeah that's just
enough dude
that's just enough so don't hit the cop
cars so much further don't hit the top
cars who would make that mistake who
would make that mistake tall boy
oh wait i don't have enough health to
walk there's an exploder on evangelo
never mind
oh where
oh man
all right guys i had a defibrillator
does it drop when i die or no you have
to drop it
son of a [ __ ] oh what are you talking
about what did i do
oh i'm being smooth
i'm being smooched
i've been
smooched oh my god good only two tall
boys inside
good god
how close were we to the end it was
right there close
no
all right we had to continue we could do
it all again no i think that's it for me
but we were so close
sure
that's very fun you know anyone who
wants to play this at home should look
in the link in the description below and
go to the epic game store and use my
creator code
my creator code my creator code
markiplier my creator code our creator
code markiplier
our my creator code markiplier yep also
thank you uh comments chat audience our
esteemed guests
gentle listeners
okay bye
you